hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast anchored protein can
I say PKA as gatekeeper for connects and
forty three gap Junction presented by
dr. GMP a senior researcher at inserm um
RS one one eight zero
I am Xavier Gutierrez of lab routes and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor visit WWF is calm
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now please join me in welcoming
dr. Pedro I will turn the presentation
over to him
hi my name is yoga Doohan I'm senior
researcher at exam the French National
Institute for Health and Medical
Research at University Park Leigh and I
will talk today and present some
techniques and tools that we have been
using to study protein protein
interaction and how by using these tools
we can we could show that the anchoring
of PKA can serve as a gatekeeper for
connecting 43g attractions
but please start with some background
with the sake campus signaling when you
have like on unnormal that bound to gpcr
the GPR can activate adenylate cyclase
which can produce second can be from A
to B second can be can have many done
effector such as the CNG's or it back
but the main dom effector is protein
kinase a or PKA PKA is composed by two
regulatory subunits and two catalytic
subunits when chef Sachi can be produced
and bound to the regulatory subunit it
releases the catalytic subunits which
can turn active against phosphorylated
serine and threonine it exists two types
of PK PK top one which is mostly but not
exclusively satiric and PK tattoo which
is mental anchored you can regulate in
space and time the activity of this
protein kinase a in time by acting
directly to the Dynalite site laced by
decreasing the production of cyclic a
and B or directly by activating
phosphorus to raise that our enzyme
which it releases this cycle game P and
in space by family of protein that we
call a gaps that are able to anchor
protein kinase a specifically into a
cell
in the human test center the human
person type is a very important organ
during the pregnancy
it will provide all the nutrients to the
fuse for the fatal growth and will help
the mother as well to the upcoming
babies so the structural and functional
unit of the human placenta is the clinic
this is kept like the tree any bath
directly into the maternal blood on the
right you could say somatic drawing of
this clinic village it's composed by the
stromal core that is possess the fetal
capital Aries and on this trommel core
are in total the we lose sighted prefer
blasts that are able to fuse together
and from the external layer of this
video is called the synthesis short of a
blast and this sensitive of August is in
contact direct with the maternal build
that race gives maternal arteries this
instead of robust is the key structure
of the human placenta it will be
responsible for all the fetal maternal
exchanges between the mum and the
fetchers providing all the nutrients it
will be also the seeds for all the
production and the secretion of all the
almonds of the pregnancy that will help
the mother to prepare the upcoming
babies but as well to help for the
sitter growth
it's possible to provide such a
trophoblast from the human presenter and
the cells in vitro able to aggregate
between 24 and 48 hours of culture and
then fuse to form a sensitive oblast
others after 72 hours of kilter on the
picture you can see proof of mythic
tales where the nuclear was then in blue
with the B and the membrane in green by
using an antibody raised against the
decimal blanking so at 24 hours of
control you could see as an aggregation
at 70 12 capture you could see a large
citizen area in which you have nuclei to
stick together this is a syncytium this
functional differentiation is also a
combined by an increase of production of
almond of the pregnancy such as HPL for
human peasant elect again an SD for
humankind in Bernadette ravine increase
that is associated with the operation of
the synthesis of prefer blast without
cell fusion there is no sense in cell
formation and no pregnancy at all for
many years now we have been studied this
fission process and we have found that
many effectors can help the fusion for
instance the EGF and the receptor or the
ACG and the receptor initiates the
process of fusion this was we called
compete on stage so ACG is also produced
by the synthesis of trophoblast and act
as an autocrine parity Luke to help
diffusion of the statute of Oblast then
we also find some proteins such as seto
one or the gap Junction protein
connection 43 that has is player role in
this area aggregation that is the
commitment stage and finally the lipid
barrier regime is in charge by
sensitives
so we wanted to know if the PKS
signaling is involved in the cell fusion
process and for that we treated the
cells with a CG or a CG wear and an
antagonist underpin a protein can is a
signaling that we call the h89
when we treated the cell with a CG we
could see that there is already after 24
hours of control the prison circle since
assume that we don't have in the control
this is summarized on the east grams
where you can see the linear increase in
the percentage of fusion at fusion index
but once we treated the cells with a CG
and h89 that block the cyclic AMP EPK
signaling then we can observe presence
of aggregation already and still at 72
hours of culture that's also summarized
on the Easter blank on the right at 72
hours of control you could see a
decrease in level of freedom index so
this indicates that the decay signaling
induced prefer blast field
said earlier you can control in space
the protein kinase a activation by
anchoring the regulatory subunit to a
family of protein that we call a gaps
for egg and as anchoring protein this is
large family of protein the don't share
a needle ology of structure but they
share four points that needs to be to be
present in this family first they asked
how to contain otk anchoring domain that
we call a canal anchoring domain then
they also have to contain a unique
subsea retargeting domain so this a
casts have to be localized into the
nucleus mitochondria or and assume for
instance or other proteins they also
have to present the ability to form a
complex with other signaling molecules
such as phosphorus Tara's pasta disease
or other kinase and finally they should
directly bind to Orca localize with
specific PKS substrates in order to
authorize the phosphorylation quickly of
the target by the catalytic subunit and
this will provide a be logical defect
that can observe it's possible to
dissociate the anchoring of PKA from the
a cap are using anchoring protein
deserting peptide or PPI that will
compete the anchoring of the regulatory
subunit through a caps it exists that
different type of PP is the type one
specific entering the certain peptides
caller:i ad will serve super IPS which
is a specific type to and carrying the
circling peptides and some peptides that
dissociate to get type 1 and type 2
called HD 31
so we treated ourselves with either
raiad Osterberg abs that dissociate the
anchoring of pique type 1 and type 2 or
the scramble control and pretty to cells
with a cg to promote cell fusion and
what we could observe is 1 we treated
ourselves with Riyad or super a GPS we
then decreased trillions of fusion
compared to the scramble and trade
themselves the DS indicate that
anchoring of DK through a gap controls
for further cell fusion so we want it
next to identify the expression of a
caps express into trophoblast and for
this we decided to develop mass
spectrometry analysis essay so we
generate p destination vector including
the regulatory subunit type 1 or type 2
with a flag tag into a plasmid that will
be transfected into e.coli BL 21 we
generate this recombinant protein and
purify this PK our flag protein by using
cyclic AMP E agarose beads we detach the
beads from the protein recommendin
protein by using excess of cyclic AMP E
and then the recommendin protein were
mixed with live sets from either pool of
SATA tofu blast or pool of censorship
trophoblast in order to fish a caps
express in both sides then we came with
an NT flag magnetic beads to enrich the
complex PK r and a caps and deep
fascination and all these the peptides
were sent to LTP orbitrap for a cap
identification and we found many a cap
Express into the cells either Institute
of a blast arsons is sort of a blast a
cat specific for type 1 and type 2 and
from a cap that are Express specific for
type 1 and type 2 that we call dual a
cap
so in order to this affair which a gaps
are involved into the control of cell
fusion we decided to realize a native
screening by using s RNA so we design a
serenade for the a gaps that have been
found in the mass spectrometry analysis
and are using cuba's are we able to
measure the level of knockdown by using
this as RNA and in same with culture we
can resolve so the impact of this as RNA
on diffusion index and what we could
observe is that central fected with a
Serena Serena present the highest level
of decrease in cell fusion not indicate
that this protein could be interested in
into the control of cell fusion so what
has rain is Israel is an on a cat it's
Niram protein at the same as predixion
and moisten it contain a friend domain
that's linked to other proteins such as
eb b CT or other exchangers for instance
you have a helical domain this is a
central domain that link to PKA type 1
and type 2 and the sitting-down
domain that was known as you know to
link to actin so what we did we treated
themselves with ezrin s RNA or to
scramble and protected the cell with
like affect them in 2000 series and then
we could see there is decrease in the
expression of his range compared to the
Scramble and this is also associated
with a decrease in the level of fusion
as you can see aggregation cells and
decrease in the histogram but then we
wanted to reconstitute the fusion so we
could respected the cell with ezrin sRNA
and a plasmid that will generate a GFP
as rain as RNA insensitive and in that
case we were able to reintroduce the
cell fusion that you can see the
operation of the green syncytium so then
we generate another destination vector
that will produce a GFP is Rena Cernan
sensitive in which we make mutation into
the protein kinase a domain so this
clustering does not present the
possibility to bind PK and in that just
we are not able to risk you the cell
fusion process and we found green
ingredients itself this means that the
PK anchor to Ezrin promotes cell fusion
beyond all the proteins that we found in
the laboratory to be involved in the
control of gabyong of the cell fusion
sorry we found that connection for this
which will be important in trophoblast
infusion and dissociation gap junction
connection 43 is expressed in the
trophoblast and you need six connects in
to form a connection and to connection
can lock each other to form a junction
to allow cell to cell communication cell
communication promotes a fusion in the
trophoblast and this connection can be
phosphorylated by many kindnesses such
as PK PK c or earth the PDF of both
sides are located in to the amino acid
364 and 373 of the connection and it
allows transfer of small molecules
so in order to see if connecting and
Ezria liable to form a complex together
we decided to realize criminal
precipitation by using dynabeads on
which we cross link it the antibody by
using bf3 and when we come université
today's Rhian were able to find
connection 43 but as well as decay type
1 and type 2 and the catalytic subunit
we use a quebec in which is known to
cater to a cap as a negative control and
didn't found a cap in t to be in the
same complex as is rain interestingly if
we did criminal precipitation with
connection 43 we are able to find as
rain pick a type 1 and type 2 and not
gonna make up 18 then if we realize a
decay catalytic subunit communal
precipitation and we are able to find
collects in Israel both decays and of
course in this time we found a camp 18
to be associate with PK again if we did
decay type one in your precipitation
with the regulatory subunit we found
connection 43 to be together with decay
top one is rayon the catalytic subunit
of PK but not a cap 18 and if we did a
PK regulatory 2 subunit a communal
precipitation than we found connection
43 is rayon and the catalytic subunit as
well as a cap 18 so this suggests that
it exists in the human placenta and
prefer blastic cells application clinics
in signaling complex
with Warren next to measure the water
supports this complex by using
approximate irrigation assay and using
the dueling strategy this strategy
hollow us to quantify the proximity
between two targets two proteins in the
cells by quantifying the generation of
dots that we get proximity in the 40
nanometer range
all this is working we use specific
primary antibody that's target our
protein of interest then we use specific
secondary antibody and if these both
proteins are in the range of 40
nanometers then you can generate a
signal that can be quantified by
generating a dot and this we can observe
here all the white dots correspond to
proximity of the protein of interest in
the 40 nanometer range here you can see
that Israel could tribute in we speak a
tap one cheek a tattoo as well as
connecting 43 we've to get up one end up
to
and finally as rain and connection also
co-localize together while the AGG
control didn't show any staining or dot
generation we know from before that
connection 43 were expressed mainly the
trophoblast wallow in the third cell
communication and in a less extent in
senses short of August so we're at
instance going to see where Israel would
be expressed in the human placenta so we
did communistic chemistry so here is
like placenta that we make slice and we
stain it with different
Ezrin antibody or 0.027 which is a
specific marker for profit last and with
stain as well the nucleus in blue with
that be
what you could see is is rayon is highly
expressed in since it short of a blast
layer mostly highly and a diesel pool
which is in contact with an eternal
blood but also at the city of oblast
level and mostly applicant pool of the
set up of oblast where the cells need to
fuse the census order for last the last
row showed a GG controller and they show
no staining at all so entering localized
and set off a blast and junction with
the census EO where it needs to fuse ok
so we have a complex is rayon and
connects in 43 but we wanted to know if
both buttons are directly linked
together or there is any other protein
associated at so for this we generate
recombinant protein into bacteria by
using key destination vector and
producing an ESRI nested in tagged or
connects in with a GST tag and we
basically put all proteins together and
did amino precipitation with histidine
tags so we found as rayon in Easton of
course an integer where we had
connection 43 we found connection to be
pulled on with the STD in the same
manner if we did the amino precipitation
with the GST tag now we're able to fund
connection 43 in the tubes where we had
connection 43 as well as ESRI in
increases renal s in but when we use
only GST as control we are able to put
onto GST
there was no Ezrin associate to that so
this means that connection and ezreal
interact directly
we want in next to study exactly the
minimal amino acid sequence that could
serve as a anchoring of connect Satine
and Ezreal for this we use the peptide
arrest strategy so what does Pettis
tradition say let's say you have food
protein such as Israel example with the
amino acid sequence you will generate 20
no 20 amino acids peptides and Lluis
published peptides on the filter and you
will generate another peptide with one
amino acid shift compared to the first
one and etc etc in order to cover the
wall sequence of the protein and this
peptide spot it will be spotted on the
filter and the filter will be probed
with protein of interest in our against
the GST connection 43 and then you will
reveal the interaction between
connection and is rayon by using an anti
GST a champion C body the other option
is also to use two-dimensional data
array so once you know the minimal amino
acid sequence necessary to bind to
proteins we can use this minimalism
sequence and make a shift for each amino
acid by 220 other and this will give you
the information of which amoenus is
important for the binding and which one
can increase or decrease the binding to
the peptide array with this affair the
minimal amino acid sequence necessary
for the binding and the two-dimensional
data layer will give you the minimal the
essential amino acids for the binding
so this is what we did and spotted the
complete sequence of Ezra in the filter
and probe with GST clinics in 43 or GST
along as a control each time you see the
dark dots here a black dots indicates
you have interaction between the GST
panics and 43 with the peptides 15 so
then you can this is a which amino acid
sequence is necessary for the banking
this is indicated in red so we use this
sequence and spotted again on the
two-dimensional peptide array this is on
the right part of the slide and here you
can switch each peptide that one of the
20 other in order to see which peptides
is essential for the money which one
increase or decrease the binding I
indicated in the red squares to mutation
to substitution again that shows a
decrease a potential decrease in the
association between Canadian 43 to ESRI
and we wanted to actually super this
data so we generate a new peptide array
in which we have the wild-type sequence
and in the other one we also generate at
times that's present is two substitution
and we probe with charity connection for
the tree and we could see that with this
to mutation we decrease the binding
organism to and 43 to base rain okay but
what about yourself
so we then we generate the destination
vector for GFP is reassign insensitive
presenting this to substitution and
indeed that case we are not able to
reproduce cell fusion we are the
presence of green aggregated sales
so this indicate that is read without
the ability to bind
connection 43 cell to risk yourself
fusion
as I said earlier gap junctions are
really important for cell to cell
communication so in order to measure the
communication between the cells we did
gap trap as a trap for resource recovery
after photobleaching so how this work we
charge the cells with gasoline red
orange and from thermo Fisher so this
means that all the cells are stained and
you select one cells in these cells we
use leather in order to bleach the all
fluorescence of the cells and you will
measure the recovery of the the
fluorescence all the time this means
this means that if the survival to
communicate between each other the
recovery will come from the cells in the
connect itself that able to communicate
but if the cells are not able to
communicate then you have no recovery at
all so this will give you a sort of
aspect on the right we can measure the
third sense recovery over the time of
the beach itself and this is important
to notice that this live cell imaging
and we both from these on the spinning
disk confocal microscopy so if we
treated the cells with crumble Ezrin
srna we could see here is like there is
a recovery of the fluorescence
indicating that the cells are able to
communicate and this is observed on
Easter gram here we could see the
diffusion rate constant increase but
when the cells were treated with as
rhiness RNA we have a decrease in the
communication there is no communication
or recovery from the fluorescence if now
we treated the cell with a Serena's RNA
and plasmid gfp Azure in srna
insensitive in that case we're able to
recovery trophoblasts communication but
if now we use to construct and that
produce GFP ezrin with invitation in the
pique binding domain or GFP Ezzor in a
certain sensitive not able to bind to
connection 43 then we are not able to
recovery of the fluorescence indicating
there is no communication between the
cells so this indicate that is rain
modulates gap junction communication
so we want in next to study from the
connection part and spotted on the
peptide arrayed the connection 43
sequence and prob the filter with the
GST as rain or GST alone again we can
deceive have the minimal amino acid
sequence on connection for 3 that is
necessary to bind to Israel and this
sequence have been spotted for
two-dimensional pattern array and you
can see that if we make a mutation of
this arginine by an acid a strategy here
by the Red Square you could see there is
a decrease of association between a
serine and connection for the tree
so in order to support this data we
confirm again on new petal array in
which we have this single mutation and
you can see there is no association
between Israel and connection 43 so what
about in cells so we treated trophoblast
we've connection for the 3s RNA and we
are able to block the cell fusion we
have presence of aggregation compared to
the scramble s RNA which is observed in
the fission index and the easter gram
here but if we could rotate the cell
with the connection for titurius RNA and
plus me that will produce a gfp
connection 43's RNA insensitive were
able to reintroduce a cell fusion and
the presence of the green syncytium
but if no we changed the prospect and
produce a gfp connection 43's are
insensitive that is not able to link to
come to Israel then we are not able to
introduce cell fusion and we are the
presence of the green agreed cells
this means that connection for the tree
without ability to bind is ring cell to
rescued cell fusion what about cell
communication so we use the cell the
same construct on gap frappe analysis
and here you could see that if the cells
were to do this crumble as RNA we bleach
it the cells and you can see the
recovery of the fluorescence indicating
cell communication if the cells were
treated with connecting as RNA we
bleached the cells and then after all
the time there is no recovery of the
fluorescence indicating no communication
if now we treated the cell we connect
seen as RNA and plus made encompassing a
GFP connects in 43 7 answers you give we
can select the green cells Blitz the
cells then we have a recovery of the
communication and if we change the
plasmid with GFP connection 43 7
insensitive but not able to bind to esri
can select the green cells but is the
self there is no recovery of the
fluorescence this indicate that connects
843 without ability to bind every cell
to rescue Junction communication
like I said earlier connection 43 can be
phosphorylated by many kindnesses and
decay also here is a pro representation
of the c-terminal part of the connecting
43 I stand in red all the serum that can
be phosphorylated interestingly in the
city mean extreme see terminal part you
could see six areas that can be
phosphorylated until now many people
found that only the centricity forward
phosphorylated by decay but what about
the others I indicated also in the
arginine in pink here that is the amino
acid necessary for their physician with
a theory this is interesting to notice
that this six syringe are in the same
area of binding with Ezri so in order to
figure out if PK can phosphorylate
directly connecting 43 we filter the
cells with dk inhibitors that we call
PKI or the Scramble peptide and
stimulate the cells with SATA can be or
not and one you can see in the second
game these stimulated cells there is an
increase in phosphorylation of
connection for degree in the cell
striated with combat bigger that is
reduced with the ki peptide we also
observed here the 40's absurd that no
less showed the activity of decay and
you can see that in presence of cyclic
AMP e we increase the activity of big
air that is reducing presence of DKI so
this indicates that when we make the
ratio of possible connection for 3 over
the total connection for the 3 TK aims
to phosphorylate connection for 3 in
human trophoblast
what about geography and communication
so here the cells were treated with B
today which is a classic inhibitor for
gab Langton communication that blocked
the communication compared to the
control the healed cells were treated
with crumbled EDI we also and stimulate
with a CG were also able to observe the
communication between the cell that is
completely block or abolish by entry to
the cells with PKI so PK midgets can
function communication in yemen
trophoblast other said earlier the
anchoring of PK through a gaps in our
guest Ezrin can phosphorylate directly
target and give political effects if we
use anchoring the circuit peptides uses
a biblical effect due to the distance of
the catalytic submit that does not
phosphorylate the target anymore and
this is what we did here we treated the
cells with rye and our cibele Jabez
if you remember this is PK type 1 and
decayed up to specific anchoring the
circling peptides or both of them and
stimulate the cells with a CG and what
you could see is when the cell virtual
disk with this peptide we completely
decrease the phosphorylation of connects
in 43
compared to the scramble control so this
indicate that anchoring of PK is
necessary to phosphorylate pennington 43
in human trophoblast
what about gatherings and communication
arrogance is gap trap analysis so the
cells in cells treated with campbell
royale or scrambles back FAS you
consider ease can murdered anti cellular
communication with the recovery of the
fluorescence in the cells the either
cells were treated with either Riyad or
Tsubaki ikbs alone then you can observe
no recovery at all and decrease in and
SLR communication so this indicates and
support the primary data that we found
with ESRI in showing that the anchoring
of PKS facilitates clamp functional
communication in Yemen trophoblast okay
but then we wanted to exactly know which
Syrians weather would be phosphorylated
on connection 43 for diet we generate
phosphor peptide array and for this we
used connection 43 possible sequence
that we thought to be DJ specific and
introduced single or multiple
combinations of serine substitution with
alanine and spotted this peptide on
filter and then the filter were subject
to PDF or full transfer as si so each
time the PK can phosphorylate
the peptides you can measure by the
radioactivity or there is no
phosphorylation you will see no
correlation at all so this we didn't get
the PK phosphorylation cycling
connection 43 and this is what we
observe here on the left part and right
that is the quantitative analysis of the
PK activation so what you could see is
that there is two wonderful system show
the phosphorylation level of a conscious
is PKA phosphorylation sequence this is
in black or gray you will see a crab
sequence for frailty by decay so both of
them are highly phosphorylated by decay
and as negative control we use the
consensus ck 1 d phosphorylation
sequence that shall no phosphorylation
at all by DK and we use as a control
the wild-type sequence of conic sinfully
that show in bloom phosphorylation by
decay interestingly if we introduce one
single mutation each time for 75069 or
7373 we have a decrease in the
phosphorylation level compared to the
other four suicides so this is what we
observe here the data on the phosphor
peptide are a original data on the left
on the right corresponds to the analysis
of this PK activity so we generate
peptides we call such as PKA
phosphorylation site this is the black
histogram and in Christ Oh Graham you
will see the creb with be careful
solution side sequence and both are
really pose related by PK as a negative
control we use a constant C CK one g p--
oscillation sequence that is not
phosphorylated by decay well if you use
the wild type sequence of connecting 43
which is the blue one you can see a
phosphorylation of the sequence by DK
indicating that decay can phosphorylate
that sequence if in that sequence we
include one substitution in seven three
sixty nine or seven three 73 by an
alanine we decrease the level of decay
phosphorylation but more interestingly
if we include a double annotation
substitution of these two amino acid
serine 369 and seven 373 when alanine we
completely reduce the PKA
phosphorylation so this indicate that at
least on the filter together for alleged
connection 43 on 73-69 and 373
to ko support this data we decided to
make
post for proteomic analysis we have
cells and stimulated accumulated with
Sachi can be another to activate the
cyclic AMP EPK signaling and then
realize amino precipitation with
dynabeads
to enrich all the connection for
make pizza nation and analyze the
peptide on altitude orbit riped a to
identify the phosphor site and here are
listed all the petals with respond or on
the area that we're interested in and
what we find is like in the basal
condition many of the series has been
basal already correlated such as 36455
65 68 and 69 but the most interesting
like upon acute stimulation cyclic AMP
e1 peptides came out is the oscillation
on syringe 373 or serene 372 so based on
these two analysis prefer peptide array
and for proteomic analysis we can
conclude that the postal ation of
connection 43 uncertain 373 actually is
actually due to an activation of settle
can be
what about the contract in cells so we
generate new destination vector that
will produce a GFP connection for the
tressaurians as it is not able to link
to
Ezrin with substitution that mimic
either non phosphorylated form of the
serine which is institution with alanine
on turn 3 69 or 373 or for filmmaking
violence by switching this serene with
an acid aspartic the key and then
treated the cell transected the cells
with either scramble s RNA or connection
for the 3s RNA and the plasmid and what
we could see by doing this is the cells
that were affected with a scramble as
RNA present in Ciccio trophoblast of
fusion while the connection 23 certainly
toxic itself present aggregation
aggregate cells with low vision indexed
and if now we treated the cells with I
serenade + GFP clinics in 43 a certain
insensitive as earlier we are able to
introduce self in presence of a yellow
syncytium and he is now we make a
mutation substitution into this
connection 53 in order to abolish the
binding with se a reason and we are not
able to introduce this vision what about
the post for mimicking violence
each time the concert were transfected
with construction and that slack the
phosphorylation on syrian 369 N or 373
we are not able to reintroduce cell
fusion presence of aggregated yellow
cells but each time the constructs
present phosphorylation by n't we've set
a static instead of the serine on 373 or
369 with the able to introduce cell
fusion so this indicates that the
phosphorylation on serine 369 and 73 73
is very important to control the cell
fusion
so we wanted now to analyze this
intercellular communication and for this
we didn't perform gap fraud analysis
before we perform gap sleep there are
some flaws in photo bleaching so again
this is live cell imaging and we charge
the cell with can see in the red orange
and and we select instead of bleaching
or conferences as before we only select
a small area of the cells and we'll
repeat a laser beam in order to bleach
over the time the cells and if the cells
able to communicate between each other
we will also bleach the connected cells
so you can measure over the time the
fluorescence loss of the bleach itself
but also the connected cells and this
can give you which cells are actually
communicate between each other so this
is what we did here and we transected
the cells with GST control to measure
the Salar communication so we give you
the based on communication did another
expression of GFP connects in a certain
insensitive that show you I
communication and if we replace
discussed trip with cost rate that is
not linked to ESRI and we are not able
to communicate anymore but more
interestingly if we look and focus on
the fossil mimicking violence of
connection 43 each time the same 369 or
373 were not phosphorylated by
presenting an alanine substitution on
the serine we are not able to
reintroduce intercellular communication
while when this construct
show phosphorylation mimicking violence
on certain 369 or 373 then we are able
to introduce and just allow
communication
so the take-home messages is the sake
camp EP casing that controls human
trophoblast fusion esri anchors DKA and
control cell fusion in unit the center
is rayon forms a singling molecules
together with PKA and connection 43 and
Ezrin bonds to connection 43 controls
trophoblast vision and interstellar
communication
PK anchor to ESRI in fulfill a directly
connecting 43 on 73-69
and 373 and these phosphorylation sites
promotes cell fusion and enter cell our
communication so in conclusion you will
found gap junction here in the basal
state with ESRI link to connection 43 n
PK associate to a serine once you will
have an increase in cyclic AMP be
concentration you will release the CC
unit that will phosphorylate connection
for the treat on 7 3 6 9 and 373 which
will open the gate a transfer fissioning
molecules of signals that we'd able to
start the fusion process I would like to
thanks many people that give me the
opportunity to make this work of course
I want to thank the people from the in
some 767 and more precisely bascarsija
130 Michele we did a large part of that
work but also the ENB anodic in Norway
and more precisely the taskin group
studied the stranded Alex and logic each
a PhD student been done a large part of
the work as well and the G group for the
mass spec analysis I want to find the
institute weary muscle frizzy and
Ludovico account for all the lights and
imaging and of course I want to thanks
optimizations Vic Olivia there and
Johnson succeeded give me the
opportunity to present all this work
here today thank you so much
thank you dr. Purdue for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button what answers
many of your questions as we have time
for now let's get started
first question is why did you change
from gap trap to gap clip analysis okay
thank you while you are doing gap
Junction intercellular communication you
want to monitor kinetics of
communication between connected cells
right and in both case you can use trap
analysis which is your son's recovery
after photobleaching or flip analysis
which is fluorescence lost in photo
bleaching so you have live cells that
are charged with calcium dye so that it
became fluorescent and interrupt
analysis the entire presence of the
target cells will be bleach in one run
of a laser beam and you measure over the
time the resource recovery this first
half comes from connected cells to the
target cells so this works perfectly
fine but this is a huge amount of work
for analysis and to identify the wall
how many cells are actually truly
connected to the target cells and if
they are connected then all the cells
are the connect in a similar manner
meaning if they are connected yes no and
are technically given the Morrisons or
not then we decide to switch to another
languages which is the flip si this is
something completely different you in
this case there is we choose the target
cells and you will bleach a small area
of these selected cells and you will
bleach over the time in the same area
over and over to repeat it so you really
measure you will see the first loss of
that cells this is completely opposite
of the frappe and then over you bleach
the cells the neighbor which are
connected to each other if they are
communicate communicated to the targeted
cells then they will lose as well the
few essence and then you will measure
that case the
lost not on the dacha details but
directly on the chronic itself so then
you become more accurate to murder this
dyskinetic and then you not read worried
about how much and how many cells are
directly connected to detect targeted
cells leads actually helps body analysis
all right and can you explain how you
did not find phosphorylation of
connection 43 at 7:00 364 well until now
it has been described to be the main PKA
phosphorus is well we don't know exactly
it could be many many possibilities so
we haven't found this terrain to be
phosphorylated by two main experiment
which are mass spectrometry analysis so
in mass spectrometry from this sir
indirectly phosphorylated in basil state
and by peptide ray phosphor peptide
array we haven't found a direct
phosphorylation of that site by BK
compared to two other sides so what we
have to keep in mind is that when we did
peptide already this is peptides that
are synthesized and then spotted on the
on the filter and they actually lack the
3d structure that's probably important
in real life so we couldn't imagine that
on the filter this really structure is
not on the fluid the fitness researcher
is not correctly folded and then the PK
cannot phosphorylate directly pasta
sides compared to two other and that
could be an explanation where we can son
it or as I said earlier that we do we
haven't found PK or in basis that PKS
estimation logic is in adding activation
for Allah decide these could be due to
or in you have at the Bayes electronic
activity of the kind of activity that
phosphorylate any of this
phosphorylation decide and this is not
actually observed in the on the peptide
already to the stretcher 3d structure or
we cannot exclude that PK can activate
other signaling molecule down a vector
that could postulate
indirectly disposable sides or of course
you cannot exclude or rule out that PK
does not phosphate
at all yesiree
all right and looks like we're going to
have one more question is this complex
specific to human placenta yeah and this
is a good question actually we have been
working on human percenter for over 15
years and we actually don't fight these
complex together in connection 43 as a
key regulatory gap junctions are still a
communication that leads to the
pleasantest formation that is necessary
for fetal growth and signaling all the
pregnancy actually but we actually
developed some collaboration and we are
still working on on other complexes and
all the cell type and we found that this
complex is also present in G cells for
instance that's very important for the
key regulation T reg cells in the immune
system
and also in the liver cells where the
complex is also important for the
communication between the cells we
cannot exclude that action this complex
it's probably ubiquitous and could be
present in all cells that need to
communicate between each other but in
which the tacky campy PK activation
actually play a key role
you
all right well I would like to once
again thank dr. could do for his
presentation I would also like to thank
Thermo Fisher Scientific for his making
today's educational webcast possible
and before we go I want to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
September of 2019 pretty share with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye